[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we get ready to make way for uh one of
our favorite guests he's derek henry
it was a year ago at this time we had uh
derek on he joined us
at the super bowl derrick good morning
how are you
can you hear me what's going on did you
get the news that desean watson wants
out of houston
i have heard what do you think
um i mean that's a good thing for us
you're right about that but uh
you know i just wish you the best in the
situation whatever ever happened
whatever occurred for him
do you know him yeah i know sean yes yes
sir
yeah all right and i was wondering about
uh devonta smith going to the senior
bowl which surprised i think a lot of
people but that he wouldn't
get weighed he wouldn't get measured
does that
is that a red flag should that be a red
flag for a team that you know he doesn't
he's going to wait till his pro day to
get measured
oh i mean i don't i mean i mean i don't
know that the whole situation but maybe
i mean i'm not sure if he just
wanted to go there to do uh interviews
and
you know just talk so they can get to
know him and you know build a
relationship with
some of the teams and then you know
because i know he hurt his hand in the
game so i'm not sure if
um you know that's uh for the recovery
but i'm sure he probably wanted to
be able to have a little time to train
and get his body right
and do all the things he could do so
when he's ready to
go for his pro day you know he's looked
apart and he can do
all the things he want to do any doubts
about him being successful in the nfl
not at all did you see how he played
this year he said look
he just said it wasn't even close and
you know just
ain't no question yeah and you know they
talk about size
you know it's weird because you're not
the prototypical running back now in the
nfl
you're different um do we worry too much
about
you know how big or how small somebody
is i think that
that that is a big thing that you know
people try to harp on too much and i
think a lot of guys who've been
who came out of college to play in the
nfl has you know
i mean proven people wrong and and done
it
numerous times and you know i feel like
that's another situation where this
guy's
gonna do the same thing i mean he showed
it on the field so
i mean size it really really doesn't
matter as long as you can play guard
that make plays
that's all that matters to what you put
on filming i'm sure
you know teams know that and you know
i'm sure he'll
be a top five pick and go out there and
play great and when he gets his
opportunity but i don't know if you were
labeled too big
or like you i don't know
were you too big of a running back you
know they were like a lot of things oh i
mean it was it was it was a lot of
things
to do but at the end of the day it's all
about what you do when you get here
yeah but what'd they say i mean i was
too big
um were you fast enough i was too tall
didn't have quick feet and had great
hips
oh i mean the the whole thing going on
list goes
and on ever feel sorry for somebody you
ran over
um no i don't feel sorry but i want to
do it again
well we had josh norman on and i i
i said uh hey um you you kind of
were a meme where you got uh stiff arm
by by tarak
i did ask him wait didn't you tell me to
ask
josh ask about the stiff arm where i
basically threw him out of bounds
or did i misread that i should i should
have known
you right
come on i i he said look i went for a
tackle i mean you know
so it was one play and uh you know you
still farm doing
you know yeah would you bring it up if
you saw
josh norman um i mean of course i mean
if i seen him i mean
that'd have to be something that you
know we we would talk about just like
it's been everywhere but anything i just
say hey bro i'll just
you went high
but he has to bring it up you can't
bring it up if you see him in person
right
no i would like hey how you doing man
[Laughter]
what if he went to hug you and you
stiff-armed him
oh poor josh you know uh all that
talking came back to haunt him you know
because that
you didn't have to say a word all you
had to do is just
flick him off with that that uh stiff
arm i
i still love the fact that you didn't
realize
like you went out of bounds on your own
right that was the big mistake you said
with that stiff arm
yeah i went out of balance on my own but
i was so focused on
you know i was just delivering the stiff
arm that
i didn't even realize the the impact of
it and what happened
i was so zoned in on the game and you
know
focused on him so i didn't realize what
occurred at that moment really
uh do you care who wins the super bowl
i mean no i mean it's hopefully
it's it's a good game just want to see a
good game really but you'll watch
yeah definitely watch okay but when you
watch do you watch and there's like a
bunch of people around and then there's
people who may not know the game and
then they ask you stupid questions
no i don't know i usually don't watch a
bunch of people i'll probably just be by
myself
like a girl
that's just being a girl really you know
i've only watched with a lot of people
have you watched uh tape of the ravens
game
uh yes i have i have
i waited to bring this up by the way no
you can bring it up don't wait at all
all right so so what happened how did
you get shut down
i was the same they they we didn't play
well enough
um on offense and um they
they just played better um sometimes
that happens and they had a great
great game plan and they executed it and
you know all the credit goes to them
and um we just didn't do what we need to
do on offense to be able to win that
game and
you know that definitely stuck that
definitely stunning and
definitely a lot of motivation you know
going to this off season and getting
prepared next year
i definitely never leave my my mind and
i always been thinking about that so
they played a great game all the credit
goes up yeah but you don't get shut down
you don't get shut down in december and
january you're derrick henry
no no i mean it it happens i mean i mean
it happens and um you know i definitely
got it in my head don't let it happen
again and you know and
that's all that's all i can do is it's
over with now um
i mean that's i mean it's i mean i i
can't
you know go out there and replay again
but you know i can definitely
be fueled and motivated from it uh
derek henry is joining us on behalf of
the fedex air and ground nfl player
of the year awards recognizing top
quarterback and top running back
performance
are you winning the running back
i would i would think so um i would i
would like to win to be able to
bring that trump home again other chucky
is very nice
love to be able to uh put it uh in my
trophy case
uh wait a minute are you you would be
presenting the trophy to you
i guess you could you put it like that
i would like to have it to be able to
win back to back and you know
be able to have them uh beside each
other voting is open now we'll close
tuesday february 2nd at 3 eastern fans
can vote
on the nfl twitter page poll nfl.com
fedex fedex will make a 20 000 donation
to direct relief in the name of both the
winning quarterback
and the running back totaling 40 000 who
would you give it to
quarterback wise you giving it to aaron
rodgers
i mean how can you not i cannot give it
to
aaron rodgers well by what he did this
year
um and when he's at his career i mean
just
it's unheard of we did bring back a year
ago when you joined us at the super bowl
you told that kobe story
and uh we brought it up on the year
anniversary and uh
you're at the espys and you wanted to
say hi and you got so nervous
uh i got so nervous i still still
i was thinking about that still to this
day i'm like man i was so stupid
not saying nothing
still bothers me to this day yeah but
what would you have said
i don't say i don't even know i just
want to have a conversation say
something
this this so i could have that and the
right to say that i've
i talked to him before and i ain't
saying nothing i was
i couldn't even say nothing i was just
like in all
that's the first time that's ever
happened but you're used to people
recognizing you you were probably
worried that he didn't recognize you
no i was out his words like what was i'm
gonna talk to him because i mean he was
walking by i'm just like
shout out to him by that time he was
already gone i'm like oh my god
i missed my moment i i love that it
still bothers you
it still bothers me to this day i just
uh yeah i just
think about it i'm like man you what
would you think
but you'll always have this story
because if you had spoken to him
the story wouldn't be as good as this
one is
that's true that's true you know it's
true it's still i would list out
i would like to have this story like man
i i was trying to talk to him
and then i finally did it but at the
moment i was i was so nervous but
i didn't even say nothing i didn't get a
word out
no i'm just like it happened so you just
had this
like slow motion was like saying nothing
so the next time is there anybody else
who would leave you speechless
just so if it happens that you take
advantage of the moment
no i don't i don't think so like there's
nobody in kobe's world
like jordan if you saw michael jordan
i don't know jordan jordan's up there
george
i mean that's that's that's hard that's
hard to say but he's not in your era
kobe's in your era yeah kobe's in my era
cole is my favorite athlete of all time
so i was just like
i mean dang i just i think about it
again
[Laughter]
i'll wait and bring it up next year okay
hey great to talk to you enjoy the
off-season thanks again for joining us
we always appreciate your time
hey thank you man i always have fun uh
coming on the show thank y'all for
having me chris
that's uh derek henry